it so we left the The Best For Last
yeah yeah of course
uh yeah it's a great honor to welcome my
friend Jorge Valencia Hernandez he also
requires absolutely no introduction
whatsoever so I'm just going to say
Jorge
ous uh I hope it's interesting to you
the topic uh and I chose it because we
were discussing about non-reproductive
numbers and the role of their productive
numbers and their role as thresholds for
indicators certain type of behaviors or
changes of behavior in the dynamical
systems that they describe and and I
thought it was probably also interesting
because it illustrates another kind of
complexity in the study of uh epidemics
so I'm come from Mexico The Institute of
mathematics I am a biologist by training
and I've been involved in this kind of
things some sometime so let me see how
it goes uh
what I'm going to do is to illustrate
that in order to have an epidemic
we need to have an infection at the
individual level
if you have enough viral laws at the
individual level then you may be able to
transmit the disease and you have an
outbreak at least
and the study of what they call
immunological or within host Dynamics is
long particularly grew up very strongly
with uh with the AIDS problem Alan
Pearson developed several models for
that and there are many many ways of
modeling immunological Dynamics it
depends on if you consider yeah
uh memory in the immunological system
and many many things so I'm going to use
very simple description but it's still a
classical description of these models uh
to illustrate the idea probably this is
too small but essentially the main
components that I'm going to consider
this is for kovid so not because I'm
going to talk any special about kobit
but because I think we have it all in
our minds so you have a bios it
penetrates the body then it goes into
the cell uh you can have different
treatments in different stages then the
code the protein code dissolves and then
all the genetic information goes into
the nucleus then the nucleus codes the
new violence and the new infection and
they are released so you have the
infection of uh target cells these
target cells are serve as factories to
reproduce the virus and uh and therefore
these uh this damages the body this is
the disease and uh because the virus
essentially either bought from the uh
several mechanisms but essentially
either his body mechanism or it explodes
the cell and liberates and then it
causes death to the cells so this is the
basic structure of the immunological
process the epidemiological process you
are very familiar with it we've been
discussing particularly one type of
diseases which are sir disease before
this talk is sis and I think Tom talk
about s i but this is only a very small
subset of the possibilities in that
exist in nature for infectious diseases
uh
essentially we are been looking in this
Workshop to human to human transmission
using as examples essentially covet and
some abstract
constructs but usually but essentially
there are many many more diseases
there in fact many of the more important
diseases the one that causes more
mortality are not directly to need a
diseases but back to transmitted
diseases like malaria which has worked
Dengue disease is schistosomiasis and
many others that really are a burden for
the for the uh human population and
there are others another side which are
the environmental transmitted diseases
like cholera like Toxoplasma gondi and
many others so I'm going to use this
environmental transmission to to to to
illustrate the idea behind this linking
between two temporal scales the temporal
scale at which the within host process
occurs yes all right
as you pointed out some of us are sort
of by now familiar with the picture on
the right and not on the left so Vector
means you have a little bug Which flies
from right to use at the vector what
does it mean environmental environmental
means like you are drink water or eat
contaminated Foods or how does my
disease get into the water because I uh
have because I go to support exactly
yes exactly that is that is it
so uh of course this is a very
interesting comment because many of the
environmental diseases in and some
Vector transmitted diseases are a
product of economic inequalities and
public health problems in populations
right in Latin America in Africa in many
places of the world so so that's uh one
thing so
uh
if covet gets transmitted through the
air conditioning system in this building
what you call it and so I don't infect
you directly but I sort of call off and
it gets picked up with their condition
and gets pushed on you is that no well
it's because
it goes from an organism
to another organism through the air
right
some organisms through the water to the
water but you will live in the water
right we we interact with this inert
place in which they have eggs or certain
life like oh I should imagine that it
doesn't just go directly to the water
but then in the water it has eggs or
some sort of you need still some little
bugs which do something
you you need several of these diseases
have different stages like history
stages in the environment but others
like amoebiasis for example dysentery
are directly pollution or cholera are
directly the pollution of the waters in
a large area in which to get sick when
you drink
salmonella and all this all these things
then
um
that's the thing and now the
immunological process the model I'm
going to be using is this one this one
is a very classical model uh developed
essentially exploited by pearlson and
his group and these are the target cells
the cells that are the target of the
BIOS Lambda is the production rate of
these cells K is the rate at which the
BIOS penetrates that cell m is the
natural mortality for those target cells
D is the disease the the biospiral
induced the pathogen induced DC uh death
into the uh target cells that are
infected and then they the the other
part the important part here in terms of
the viral production and the uh
production of these stuff sorry it's
infected
these are target cells naive yes and
this T star is infected infected target
cells is not a steady state or anything
like that it's just a symbols
oh yeah it's a it's a very it's a city
for cells that are infected the
difference is that now we are looking at
the the particle that produces the
disease and this this p is the
production rate that is when a per
capita so you have a cells it explodes
suppose and it liberates B virus per
time this is the rate and that so far no
humans right this is just this is
general for vertebrates in general for
patterns so I'm going to speak about
something it would be inside human or in
the inside practically in a vertebrate
this is a very general model but we can
think on humans that's okay and C is the
clearance rate so the Bible particles
live so only certain time one over C is
the time exponentially distributed that
they live inside and then they get out
of the system the model that I'm going
to use in order to link these two
processes is the SI model because it's
simpler
we could put immunity here but that is
more complicated so this is to
illustrate what uh I want to illustrate
this is enough this is just an SI model
it's a chronic disease uh so you have
the birth rate equal to the death rate
the effective contact rate
those are the basic components so we
know
many things about this thing but the
example that motivate us to work in this
this is going to work with uh ceiling
thing and other colleagues from Mexico
is toxoplasma gone
toxoplasmagondi is a interesting disease
because it practically all mammals in
the Earth
are susceptible to Toxoplasma gondi but
the only ones in which the parasite
completes the cycle it can reproduce
sexually and they produce all sites that
can infect heart attacks so it's a fair
all all species of cats are known to
Harbor Toxoplasma and to allow the
reproduction of the parasite there are
problems with this uh in Europe there
are even vaccines for pregnant women to
protect against uh Toxoplasma not here
not in Mexico not in many places but in
Europe yes uh the sexual as I said is
only on Fair lines felines I think is
the pronunciation and uh the point here
is that the cut becomes infected sheds
all sites in the urine in the feces and
then the environment is
contaminated they all cysts are
deposited there and they can last
very long then it comes a cow or it
comes another mammal it's
an ingests of all sides that all of us
except the cuts are dead ends for the
Toxoplasma but it still can cause
disease that means that the Toxoplasma
cannot reproduce inside anything that is
not a cut but it can damage the boat so
this is
for example there is a hypothesis
interesting hypothesis that Toxoplasma
gondi is a disease that has produced
evolutionary changes is controversial in
mice because the Toxoplasma goes to the
brain of the my ad mice and then changes
the behavior and instead of being afraid
of cuts they are attracted to even they
run about and they cut by them exactly
in the head and it gets infected so you
have a predation process there uh don't
know but if I know it's amazing yeah you
could you can get infected
yeah yeah so any any Mama it goes to the
restaurant he eats myself so this
is yeah because uh you got the cow it's
grass and the grass can be infested with
all sides
because it's very interesting it's scary
and I played with this cat 10 hours
disease
so now we have problems with cats
because not only do they give us candy
they also gave us the first search right
Civic cats were responsible for SAS 2002
yeah so
well or the Civic ones yeah this one
they are domestic cats yeah well
is very interesting
things around but
so you have a mammal that sheds viruses
in the environment and then from the
environment you can infect any other map
um have the cycle that's the that's the
the reason and the thing is that we have
several times involved in these diseases
in many others the transmission times
which we've raised to rise to the
epidemic
the infection times that raised to the
individual disease and the environmental
time in which they all see all sets are
resident in the environment waiting to
be ingested and produce disease so this
is the idea
and uh in us in many other diseases many
many the size of the inoculum is that
important not only for environmental
transmitted diseases but in general you
can have it so in the SI model do you
have this contamination of the
environment in this iron model right
later okay I I put together because what
I want to do is to link explicitly the
Immunology okay the epidemiological
Dynamics and now we're going to use that
through
nice nice
foreign
[Music]
there is no once you get infected you
can remain shedding viruses well not you
General mammal for a long time so that
was this is what our example but in
terms of the results I'm going to show
it doesn't really matter if it's sis or
Si
um so in terms of time scales I'm going
to use a biological insight for this so
we have
several times three times the scales
there's low time scale that they call it
the epidemiological time scale because
it takes a place in weeks months or
years
the fastest scale this immunological
Dynamics the Wheeling host Dynamics it
takes place in hours or days and the
intermediate scale that just for calling
it is essentially a slow scale that is
the resident time of the whole seats in
the Empire
so this is the model for outside I'm
going to modify it
this is the model for the weeding host
I'm going to also change it this is the
equation from the environment we have
this logistic growth equation it's an
SIS kind of model uh we have a current
capacity it's normalized to one and this
Theta V
indicates the sharing of the BIOS per
capita per infected cut or individual
here Mana so you have this is the
contaminated environment that is going
to link these two things how is it going
to do that
well before we go to that we are going
to describe equilibrium situations so
just to remind you this is the basic
reproductive number for the disease
very simple Lambda or mu
times the number of receptive popular uh
the recital's population of susceptible
population and the other is uh this one
is very simple Lambda over m is the
total number of available susceptible
cells
K Over C is the uh infection rate the
the infection actually the the number of
infected cells per per capita that
occurred during the time which you have
bidemia which is before the viruses is
cleared and okay p over mu plus M plus d
is the net production rate during the
time in which an infected cells can be
producing bikes so as a very simple
that's why we call it R naught also but
fancy R naught and this is normal or not
but these are the reproduction numbers
that uh rule
how when you have an outbreak or an
infection so humans do not get infected
by contact with the contaminated
environment oh not yet oh sorry okay so
this is that this is the components
the questions I want to ask
how does that with impose Dynamics
influence transmission
what is the effect of disease
transmission on the vital Dynamics
and uh if we have time uh some things
that I could say on the evolution of
virulence in when you couple these
systems evolution of violence is an
interesting thing because it's a very
classical area in
this processes in general uh you have
when you have a variance of urban virus
of pathogen the ones that are more
common are those of intermediate
virulence
the question is why and one of the
classical answers is that you have a
trade-off between transmission and
virulence so if you are too violent you
kill too many hosts
transmission lowers if you are very mild
you will not not get transmitted
therefore selection favors intermediate
buildings that is the classical result
so we want to know what happens when you
link these two things because you have
two systems each of them
selecting for the best strategy in
different contexts so that's it now this
is the model
you have I have since the population is
constant so I have omitted the
susceptible population n is the total
population of the mammal
so if the infection of these
susceptibles gets because they need they
interact with environment
the environment I already described the
question this is Theta Avi is the
shedding rate and this is the normal uh
within host
mathematical model but now we introduce
this Gob which is the inoculum which has
this form just embedded the general it
can be generalized but in general we
have a linear dependence of the inoculum
on the concentration of viruses in our
office in this case in the environment
this is the linked system
we can Define two times this case that's
low and fast but we are going to uh well
this is the shedding rate and this is
the knock Loop this is the linkage
between these two separated systems
and uh this is essentially the basic
things I'm going to to do uh the
approach I'm going to show you
so the between host Dynamics is lower
slow time scale The Waiting host is the
fast we are going to ignore the
transient dynamics of the viral cell
interaction because it's fast so from
the point of view uh that point of view
we are only going to focus on the steady
state of the winning host equations
because we assume that they are so fast
they reach
Staten United States before the between
homes Dynamics and then we are going to
feed that uh
steady state Dynamics into the between
course Dynamics to study the whole
system so by parts right so
this is a how we approach this two times
scale problem and uh first we look at
the isolated cases so we have the
isolated video calls dynamics that is
when there is no inoculation of viruses
you just have the disease you stop the
input from the environment and this is
the equations like this is the
repetition of that this is the basic
reproductive number I call it within
R naught so I save myself fancy letters
and uh t0 is going to be the total
available susceptible number of cells
target cells in the absence of infection
so we have the normal result if R is w0
is less than one the disease-free the
infection free equilibrium is global and
synthetically stable and if it is
greater than one then there is a unique
positive positive equilibrium inside
um
this should be M yeah right sorry yes
yes sorry yeah so uh
right so this is the basic result here
and uh we want to look at the between
hopes system so we let uh we assume that
these guys uh are in these in
equilibrium so it's a constant that
depends
on E right it's on our e is a parameter
because it's our steady state and so uh
this is the within the new within cause
reproductive number now between house
reproductive number look this part is
the normal r0
but now we have linked this are not by
uh with the reading called Dynamics this
is as you see this is the shedding rate
during the time and that can infect uh
Reservoir a mammal during the time in
which this by these all sides are in the
environment so it's a very basic
description but okay so we have a this
history equilibrium and the normal thing
happens if rb0 is greater than one then
you have an endemic state that depends
on the reproduction number but now this
reproduction number is different and so
now we want to now
put together things and see how this
interaction affects the what we know
about each system when is isolated
so
we do hosts now
the interaction this is the steady state
for the uh
with Infosys it depends now on e as a
parameter so and one important thing is
that when you have
contaminated environment that is that
the Gob is not zero then the the field
virus free equilibrium of the passage in
free equilibrium does not exist
so you don't have a system in which you
have uh zero bytes so when you have
inoculation you are you always have
viruses inside here sorry our question
do you have any um restriction on what
form Gob should take the inner Club you
should it be like GG or our function G
is a linear function for now for now but
essentially you can take it as well
gamma is less than one for example or
well but let's see letter
function maybe yeah yeah okay but then
now is linear uh is easier
then uh
I I just put these Expressions there
because these are just formulas but you
can solve
the differential equations for the
equilibrium and you get this and my only
intention for doing this thing is to
show two things one that now the the
SE expressions for the equilibrium
values of infected cells and uh target
cells tiger sets now depend on the
within house reproduction number and
since these things are
v v now is affecting uh is going to
affect the Dynamics of the the between
cost system so just to make sure that
you have this picture there now uh this
thing that is appears in the basic
reproductive number for the between Code
system depends on rw0 so we have linked
both systems and uh one particular thing
is that if RW 0 is greater than one you
can take the limit when the environment
goes to zero that is the contaminated
environment disappears so when this goes
to zero then if rw0 is less than or
equal to 1 then the limit is zero but if
RW 0 is greater than one then this is
the
viral load that you will have in that
case so yeah one more question sorry so
the reason the virus is free equilibrium
doesn't exist is sort because
equations we have influx from the
environment okay it's not zero it's not
zero okay
so I have
so I have a related question which seems
that for this to hold you really want to
think of it as that environment really
acts really fast and then it sort of
serves almost as in
external replenishing of the virus
inside the population
if I made the times the other way around
would it be the other way around would
then only they are not
the latter are not meta and the other
one not
well you're right yes I think I uh I I'm
so does it mean that in reality actually
both do matter because well yeah because
it's not infinitely faster it's just a
thousand times faster
yeah well so would I need both asked to
be really larger than one or what is uh
uh well we'll see what happens when the
this hypothesis in this hypothesis you
you can have
are the within the the between cost
reproduction number less than one and
you still can have equilibria but uh you
are right probably uh which I should be
clear on the Dynamics of e because why
I'm assuming that is at equilibrium
right
right so you are already one of them in
equilibrium and then you use it as input
first yeah so that so I'm assuming that
these guys to the environment and
between whole systems are constant from
the point of view of the fast system so
it's so fast that changes in the other
subsystem is are not noticed so I assume
those are constant right so if if I
change the order of which is fast which
is slow what's that change the order of
the are not the importance of one or not
versus the other
oh I said
but that wouldn't happen right because
you cannot have an epidemic faster than
the infection it takes inside the body
because you need to transmit
so they they within whole city has to be
faster than the scale at which you you
are producing an outbreak
so it's a biological argument
but in principle you're right in the
sense that if you have two different
reserved words and one of them is on the
faster scale then then depending how you
set it up one of these are notes will
matter but the other will not right so
that's right this is this is the
invasion of production number because
one is a study statement you introduce
them yeah okay essentially this is
visualization I think so yeah and we'll
we'll see now how they interact but in
this case both play a role okay okay so
I I haven't thought the possibility so
so now for the between holes we do host
these are going I'm going to what I said
a moment ago this is the slow system
both of them
so this uh local is lower is lower than
the Dynamics in at the individual level
so if this thing is greater than one
then as I showed you before the limit
when the environmental contamination
goes to zero is this one so this is the
initial viral density
and we can build the new
uh be between holes reproduction number
that now depends on this parameter
right so you I have now this thing
linked so are we not here I already uh
described this this is the this and that
is it should be m
this is the basic reproduction number of
the isolated system and this is the
production
of the sharing of viruses within the
timing which the environment is present
and here we have that the this is free
this is classical result zero zero
infection free equilibrium if RW 0 is
greater than one W zero is
asymptotically local asymptotically
stable if the reproductive number
between host is less than one and it is
unstable if this is greater than one
which is the classical result if this is
less than one then is less it's just
locally asymptotically stable that this
is pretty cool Okay so
questions
okay now
um I already described that so I I skip
it
um just to show you these are
simulations to see that one is fast and
deep than the other this is the uh this
is the uh for what is this is the within
Code system this is for the target cells
infected target cells and biases and
this is for the Environ for example and
uh and we have this these two different
scales obviously it's faster so just
just to illustrate that on the
reasonable parameter values biological
significance this this works as as state
um
and the point is that here can appear
multiple endemic equality and this is
where both reproduction number play are
so I put here the
dynamical system we are looking at and
by solving these two things we can have
I and uh the expression for I in terms
of this is the constant value of b e is
a solution of this function
which is a complicated function but it's
algebra simple but we have several cases
if r w zero this is the within hose
reproduction number is greater than one
and the within holes between holes
reproduction number this is the epidemic
reproduction number is less than one
then we can have several scenarios H Max
the maximum of this this is a concave
function uh we have two possible endemic
equilibrium that exists I will talk
about the stability later if is zero
then is unique and this is less than one
no equilibrium exist
if r w 0 is less than one then these two
exist is unique I know equilibria in the
other case and if uh both are positive
in this case that's probably the thing
they were thinking in this case this
only one it doesn't matter how what the
value of this as long as they are
greater than one and the only comment is
that is hmax uh requires that this
derivative will be greater than zero
that requires that the inoculum function
satisfies certain misbounded below by
rw0 so everything is connected here and
the important thing is that you see our
they are not of the epidemic system has
two equilibria when RB is less than one
that's the uh thing so this is what I
say here
to positive equilibrium so feasible
biologically uh reasonable equity
uh for the between costs yes yeah for
the for the other industry
so this is what I have said
so given that the time sets are not
infinitely related you may wonder
whether if sort of one is just on a
thousand times slower than the others
are maybe one of these becomes unstable
or not well I'll I'll see the next the
next uh I think is the next oh well
uh
a discretion of backward bifocation but
this is this is what we are looking at
here so in general
in general in general models uh you have
a parameter A reproduction number
usually and as we were discussing last
two weeks and uh moment ago
uh essentially you have a transcritical
bifurcation this slope is positive as
you move the parameter above one then
you have you lose the stability of the
disease for equilibrium and you gain
stability in the endemic equilibrium and
this branch is a continuous function of
the parameter
here uh there are you don't have that
scenario you still have the
transcritical but now the slope is
negative so uh is a different picture
prices because that you have two endemic
equilibrium
one is unstable the other is locally
stable and the the C3 equilibrium
behaves normal
the problem here is that we have a
problem with statuses right if we uh use
r as a control parameter and we are in a
neighborhood of this equilibria we'll be
going uh suppose we start here we
increase the parameter instead of going
up slowly
suddenly we when we reach a certain
value here below one we have a jump
and this will be the attractor
this is and the same way if you uh go
backwards then uh you'll jump to the
specifically around until you get to
this part so you get attracted you jump
here you follow you go the other way
you're right selector so you have a
hysteresis phenomenon yes there seem to
be a piece of a curve below the well
because I draw it that's my lack of
ability with Mathematica I couldn't get
rid of that here I I I this is what's
done by one of my students and I try to
reproduce it here but I couldn't but I
no actually I think if EA is correct if
you go to if you don't care about
biology
then this is stable because this this
this actually goes like this
so these goes like this are below but it
doesn't but for us it doesn't negative
infection right here right so we don't
care so but here's two models this paper
is extremely
um uh influential it's one of the first
few papers to establish the presence of
barcode verification epidemiological one
yeah this is uh two murders you have to
claim the credit the model is
very simple
you have mortality you have a
vaccination rate you one in the disease
weight the vaccine wins and probably the
natural uh immunity also is temporal
then you have V this is uh
this is you can get from this vaccinated
then the vaccine got certain efficacy
that can protect
and these guys uh they is weighing in
Wayne's people die
and then infected is just beta s i
Sigma beta b i minus gamma plus mu i and
r equals gamma I minus mu plus Theta
this is the basic thing so the
reproduction number here is the normal R
naught which is beta over
gamma plus mu times if I remember well
it has to be something like
B yeah
y minus Sigma Phi plus
Omega plus Theta
divided
so this is this is the basic
reproductive number for this model and
in this model essentially what you have
let's call it B
you have r0
and a function fee of certain parameters
in this case the parameters b p
Omega and Theta and sigma
and depending on where are these
parameters you can have either this
diagram or you can have that type
so
essentially if you have in general
because
I haven't looked at the space that these
things generate but essentially for low
efficacy
uh low low coverage
and uh
short warning you are more prone to have
this scenario
than this one yeah if you have a perfect
vaccine for example you have that you
have the transcritical right back over
there uh we naively because this was a
naive exercise we substituted the values
that we have or these different vaccines
that we have for kovid in Mexico we
applied seven
substituted into the this very simple
model and all of them fortunately render
this kind of thing so
but this is this is the classical
backward bifocation and this thing
appears in the model that time
it's coming to you
okay questions everything so what would
be the mechanism that causes well in
this case this one we know is a vaccine
being perfect yeah but in the other one
yeah what causes that
I said what did you say luckily
to take the reproductive number way
below one
to reach one will not be enough like in
this here
so you will be the the little thing here
is not that good they can if I
exaggerate
I think uh they should be this and this
is one table and then
foreign
clear picture so that's the point here
is a true parameter that will get rid of
your disease very suddenly will be a
jump
so in this case backward verification
make the effect control this is a lot
more difficult because it depends on
initial conditions what are not selected
one it is above the stable manifold of
that saddle point then you go up to the
stable Branch if it's below you come
down to yeah I'll show some pictures oh
sorry okay
so we have that published some time ago
and you know holding a few things uh
developed from here so in the case
coming back to our to to the to the
model
uh this is uh essentially the function H
and you can see uh how we can have two
positive equilibrium
for values lower than a certain that
this is a threshold there are stuff that
I put here so this is below one is above
one and this is the same picture but
with all of them below one so we can see
that we can have both
two equilibrium endemic equilibria in
this case okay
and this is what uh Ava was describing
if you reduce the trajectories then
there is the stable the unstable
state is somewhere here so it depends on
initial conditions you you start with a
large number of infected people you will
go to the in the mixed state if not you
will go today this is priest
oh uh this is
this is essentially the the thing are
now on the stability which described
here but
you can look at the pictures this is
locally asymptotically stable this is
locally asymptotically stable for these
conditions right and this is subtle not
the one that is here
so that's the full picture of uh things
are now what produces this thing that's
uh that's uh one something uh and it has
to do with how we LinkedIn we don't know
if I have it
well this is just the picture of the
slow manifold and the fast management
right
how how it goes so
it works for the within calls within
consistent let me see if I oh well I
have the pictures here this is just
I mean a portal description you have a
large vision of multiple interior
equilibria and so forth let me see if I
have what you asked
uh
it has to do with
foreign
in this case for the
vaccine what you have is a since the
efficacy of the vaccine is not large
enough then you have a surplus of
susceptible population that is theft
into the into the general population
that is affected by the receipt very
quickly
and so that generates probably that and
in this case I think it's the same but
now the environment plays at role like
holding for set of parameter values the
speed at which you are feedback into the
endemic State into the Dynamics of the
disease is generates circles we have a
similar setup for cholera but we didn't
have a backward application I think we
have contribution from them so you have
you have this thing but it's not
logistic yours is logistics and remember
that this e depends on on the winning
Coast
so it's uh this e
depends on where is this
yeah
this B depends on r w zero so this also
plays a role
so it depends uh what is the value of
this in order to have the others if this
is greater than one then
if you uh
his number is
oh well I just substituted Sigma Phi the
Cobra the sigma and the on the warning
for in this model and I got the
on the list this is
I don't know I I I I think
the other is other thing
right yeah uh well my guess will be I
think the mechanism leading tobacco
advocation tomorrow is the logistic
contamination of the environment yeah if
it's not Logistics if it's linear for
example you probably wouldn't have that
it's a quadratic
non-linearity probably but yeah because
IH is a quadratic right that's why
you're saying that yeah yeah but it's
very interesting to find what the reason
very nice so that's that's the thing and
um
well I'm going to be quick on the
following uh then the next problem that
we want to approach is the evolution of
violence in general
uh
systems biological system optimize
certain parameters to improve Fitness
right the capacity of reproduction and
be successful in an environment
the problem that is that we have a
system an individual level in which the
viruses is going to optimize the way it
invades
this is the the cells and the other is
the transmission who have another hosts
in order to invade that host and
generate the disease there
so uh
in general uh you have a
trade-off between virulence and
transmission in this case infection
breathing host and you have
buildings and transmission in the
between clock system and the question is
will the same value of the key
parameters will coincide in both of them
in what I I mean uh well let me skip
this it's just a description and uh
we'll now incorporate disease induce
that right
in order to to measure Bay lens better
and uh have this trade of clearly stated
because now this is the disease related
to the production of virus
and this is the same model
but now you remember in the reproductive
number P over M plus d
we call it V of p p is the production
the board size this this whole thing but
p is the production of viral virus per
cell
and now we are going to make the this
the killing of the target cell infected
target cells depend on P
right and uh this is uh the measure this
is the measure of Fitness for the virus
inside the body
uh
and as an example I'm going to assume
that the shedding of the viruses has
deformed
with C positive that the this is induced
that rate depends on the target cells
this is the equilibrium target cells
after infection so this number is
smaller than this one and so this is a
measure on how damage is the tissue
and therefore it's we assume it as an
indicator of violence so the death rate
is directly related to these different
this is a way of doing it there are
several ways of doing and uh our D is uh
I've already said that and so
we are assuming also that biologically
the viral production rate is bounded is
a maximum has a maximum biologically it
cannot grow forever so you have a bound
on the number of viruses that each cell
can produce right and um
with these forms then uh there is a
critical point here for D we have that
and we'll Define p Star as a minimum of
P Max or for the option right so this is
as far as the bottom production rate is
concerned then uh we can again solve our
equilibria now in terms of fee and we
can look at Theta the sharing rate as a
function of P or a function of Delta
remember Delta is that this is induced
death rate and P is the production rate
so we can look at them both ways the
same this is the same and now the
reproduction number the between holes
reproduction number we can look it as a
function of p and we want to optimize
this in terms of P or we can look at it
instead as a function of Delta
C is a parameter that allows us to uh
shape the form of theta
so we will see see can be it's positive
and I'm going to show you an example
with Z less than one
uh
then uh we have an optimal value we can
compute these things I'm going to be
quick on this and let's call P plus and
Delta plus they're all team optimal
values derived from the optimization of
these quantities
uh for between host Dynamics for the KZ
less than one
and uh if you do I think uh just to
conclude uh
pictures are more the same more than
thousand words they say and you have two
scenarios right essentially if you uh
this is induced that rate is less than
the optimum calculated before then you
have that both this the the basic
reproductive number for the within Code
system and the basic reproductive number
for the between home systems are
optimized for the same value of the
viral production rate
but if uh dmax the the optimal is less
than
the maximum decision deals that rate
then the Maxima are different
for the within code reproduction number
is a larger number than that required to
have an optimal transmission trade-off
uh in the within host reproduction
number so you have this this
contradictory one is not contradictory
these different aims that different
elements of the system have in order to
produce an infection and I think that
with that let me just we're looking at
Vector parameters is too but that is to
prolong too much this and this is uh
what I have to say to you thank you very
much
questions are there any questions
that should be one question I I will
still keep on asking you about the
mechanism that I'm I'm very interested
in mechanism
because it's the first time I've seen
I've seen many couple models models that
couple immunology and epidemiology I
don't remember seeing
any of that has about the verification
but it has to do with the inoculum rate
yeah yeah
and uh
and as you say the logistic growth of of
the environment that you have as a
tradition
in there that could be yeah
so no no not to that particular question
I probably do not but but my question is
different so it seems like within host
you are assuming certain
dispersal-like system for for the
interaction between the cells and and uh
and the virus
how much
individual heterogeneity would affect
this because you know right now you have
these sort of averaged idealized models
and there should be lots of variation
between among different roles right it's
just going to to destroy potentially
some of those effects I don't think he's
going to destroy it but at your right
uh
this is an average behavior and really
what
have is probably age of infection right
you have the age of infection you have a
distribution and then based on that you
can look at the same problem or you
could have some individualized behavior
of these immune cells or you know some
kind of different infectability right
well the the the thing that makes this
work is that the within host system has
a unique globally asymptotically stable
uh positive equilibrium that allows us
to take the the steady state values and
plug them into the between whole system
to derive all these things if the system
has Cycles or the disease-free uh the
the endemic the equilibrium of the
wedding house is not globally stable
then uh probably the same thing holds
but then you have to do much more work
uh to prove that this is based on that
particular thing and I uh underline this
because there are many many ways of
modeling the interaction of the immune
system with with pathogens and we chose
a very classical one
special
this is a question
thank you
um so very much like Abba I want to
think about this backward by bifurcation
could you put equations up uh that you
do that
that's not this one no this one the one
that you see here
yes
I can get rid of the circles yeah
the contamination and the way is
the items
so so somehow it's going to be that
Logistics
having more
eye around
this is the shedding
with the shedding so it's uh essentially
a triple Master actually right I D times
E Yeah
so the rate of increase depends on the
bike
e shows up in the G of e term
yeah
in the expression sorry which one do you
solve first
uh for the for the fast system we
consider that this is constant because
this goes fast so from the point of view
dynamics of this system these are
constant values so Jesus yeah
[Music]
dni system right
so that's why I would want to answer the
question mathematically is to apply the
yeah so the other thing I would ask you
also relate to
okay so in this case the production rate
of one impacted CD4 cells is constant
right so but for hivas for example we're
not one of the eight stage the
production rate
no the Lambda the Lambda here no no no
the T equation the production yeah yeah
so at the end I think one of the end
eighth stage for example yeah yeah three
different card because remember that
this is for a general mammal yeah
General system theoretical just keep it
simple yeah but uh yeah if we specialize
in certainly cases yeah now that's
that's really very nice very nice
presentation any more questions any more
comments okay in which case that then
core here one more time thank you
foreign